justement c'est une chanson de voyous
bien allez-y s'appelle betty
une chanson des prisons et beaucoup de
poètes en prison c'est vrai beaucoup
on peut être en prison pour des idéaux
pour sa façon de vivre ça dépend
[Musique]
tu n'as pas sommeil tu fais tu vas
tout court chez
et comme un chat triste perdu sur la
liste des objets trouvés
la nuit carcérale
tombant sur les dames et celui glacé
aller et venir
soleil et souris sont de l'autre côté
[Musique]
ces murs et grillages ses portes et ses
cages ces couloirs ses clés
cette solitude
si du récit rue qu'on peut la toucher
ce rayon de l'ue sur le sol à lui
visages oubliés
de celui que tu aimes qui tire sur sa
chaise comme un loup blessés
petit
faut pas craquer
betty
faut pas plonger
et
je sais
ils t'ont couché là
et puis
ils ont fermé leurs barreaux d'acier
midi
vous pas pleurer
meti
il faut pas tremblé
je sais
tu vas rester là
eh ouais
lui jamais rêvé
le
je te dis je t'aime
on secours points dans ce long baiser
tu es ma frangine
juste une féminine que j'avais vie mais
tous
je te donne ma force memo et mais nantes
pour te réchauffer
jeu et la morale
les prisons centrales les maisons
d'arrêt
[Musique]
je n'ai pas sommeil je fus lui je vais
et j'ai composé
[Musique]
une chanson d'amour
une chanson ce coup pour l'autre côté
pour ceux que l'on jette dans les
oubliettes dans l'obscurité
pendant que les gens dorment au fond du
confort sans se réveiller
[Musique]
le tir
pas craqué
betty
faut pas plonger
je sais
ils t'ont coucher
et puis
ils ont fermé leurs barreaux d'acier
tous
faut pas pleurer
betty
vous pas tremblé
je sais
on se retrouvera
aïeux
[Musique]
en plein soleil
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]